ostfriesland liegt im nordwesten
deutschlands direkt an der nordseeküste
und ist von deichen geschützt
windmühlen sind typisch für diese region
auch fischkutter sieht man häufig wie
hier in dem dorf greetsiel wo ein
moderner eric und nicole übernachtet
haben
kauft krabbeln und pult sie bereitet
damit die spezialität greetsieler
krabben brot zuwarfen
die aufgabe sorgt für ärger gibt wenn du
sagst dass eine frauensache ärger egal
wer nachher kocht zuerst müssen die
krabben besorgt werden
kaufen können sich der herren geschenkt
das ginge schneller als gedacht dann
brauchen sie fünf sechs sind angezündet
die drei haben glück die nette dame lebt
sie auf ihr fischerboot ein das im hafen
liegt
sie will ihnen zeigen wie man krabben
pult es handelt sich um doping und dies
deutsche krabbenpulen meisterin
in dem die klausur in der hand hielten
die investiert man muss
können sie uns eigentlich nie
sie brauchen viel konzentration das kann
ich im schlaf können sie dabei eine an
den 10
das ist zum ersten mal und ich hatte vor
bis heute noch nie gegessen
auch wenn ich ein favorit bin für handy
noch mal sitzen oder scheuen und so
gesehen war weniger geworden
wir haben einen für sich nur noch zur
begrüßung wir festgestellt dass im nord
und seine leute moin moin faymann und
hier sagen zeigen sie nur 9
das tut mir leid
möglich seien
wir wollen auch fragen ob wir vielleicht
irgendwelche benutzen können wir das ja
nicht kennen da wieder ein rezept das
konzept kenne ich auch das ist tradition
weil die ganzen krabbenkutter liegen wir
im hafen die fangen selber die krabben
und früher in der nachkriegszeit und so
weiter es gab keine lebensmittel außer
die aus dem eigenen garten und es war
ihm halt vollkorn wo das brot gebacken
wurde und die eigenen karten vom
kutscher und daher ist es entstanden
na so was hatte jeder selber aha zum
greetsieler krabben brot gehört
traditionell schwarzbrot und jetzt ist
auch klar wer in der küche arbeitet alle
gemeinsam
genau so dass wieder aus zwiesel das ist
aber schmeckt es dem ostfriesen auch
wirklich und dafür gibt es ein ticket es
steht 4 3 für team nord